Let's take a ride on the train of physics.
Now this is a very special train.
It moves along the tracks at a perfectly
constant speed, we call it V and unlike every
train you've ever ridden this train doesn't
bump, it doesn't sway from side to side,
it goes perfectly straight.
Now let's say you want to do an experiment
on the train, to figure out what the difference
is between motion at a constant speed and being
at rest. One experiment you might want to do
with the help of your mohawked friend
is to drop an apple. While the train is moving
at constant speed just see what trajectory
the apple takes as it falls. My question is
from your point of view, so here you are
watching this experiment on this train
as it goes rocketing down the tracks.
when you watch your friend drop this apple
which of these trajectories best describes
remember from your point of view not from some
external observers standing on the tracks,
what trajectory the apple will take,
this one, this one or this one.